[Aplausos]
soy gabri sol de anís él es mi ex novio
ex novia
estuvimos juntos por dos ámbitos más de
dos años dos años y medio dos años
rompimos por dos meses creen que ambos
superaron su relación
yo sí sí creo que sí
nada de anís es muy callado así que creo
que este tipo es alguien un poco más
extrovertido tiene que saber sobre
música y vestirse bien necesita a
alguien que tenga mucha personalidad eso
creo
i
no
[Música]
empieza a seleccionarlas
ah
[Música]
en esta linda
próxima
eres preciosa pero demasiado alta en lo
siento
me encanta tu maquillaje y buena vibra
me encanta tu cabello
tú vas para allá
[Música]
sí
para ellos estoy sudando hace calor
relajada
hola soy lis lo primero que vi fueron
sitios me encantan gracias
cómo te llamas mi nombre es gabriel esto
es raro es orgullo mi nombre es gabriel
pero me dicen gabri allison mi nombre es
brakna pero me dicen ria yo la conozco
con locura me reconociste cuando
inmediato y ahora la última jugábamos
fútbol juntas estás nerviosa y
también está nervioso
cómo te sientes en esta situación los
veía en instagram como un par de tortoló
que es raro es genial la mayoría de las
personas no pueden imaginar respirar el
mismo aire que sus de a qué te dedicas
voy a la universidad estudió diseño y
arte digital así que trabajo con diseño
gráfico y cosas así que él es diseñador
gracioso genial estoy empezando apenas
dure cuatro años en la universidad y me
acabo de cambiar yo hago pelucas
me encanta mucho la moda también también
sueño con tener mi marca de ropa yo no
sé temo que en a la gente debería
hacerlo hay muchos tipos de persona en
el museo a alguien le gusta es cierto
les son tus tres cantantes favoritas y
son sólo tres charles kanye y luego a mí
me o la música es muy importante para ti
si logró identificar el estilo musical
de una persona puede inferir su
personalidad firme tus favoritos primero
the weekend siempre mike miller y kanji
tengo un tatuaje de matt miller es en
serio sí justo aquí en la costilla dios
mío
[Risas]
quizá eso de vamos a hacer si vieras a
denis en una aplicación de citas lo
aceptaría se sincera imagina que no está
aquí
[Risas]
su perfil necesito más información quizá
lo aceptaría todo depende de cómo fluya
la conversación
llevas mucho tiempo soltera bueno
terminamos hace 22 meses nuestras vidas
tenían rumbos diferentes y terminamos
cielo en marzo terminé una relación de
dos años lo hice porque no quería una
relación de larga distancia era una
relación muy complicada la mayoría del
tiempo sentía que estaba sola así que
desliga te entiendes
debía terminar los dientes si bien un
grandioso alguna conducta que te dé mala
espina quiero tener mi propio espacio
hacer mis cosas y no tener que estar
juntos todo el tiempo te entiendo por
completo
quiero que sepan que yo no quería pasar
todo el tiempo
y no era yo bien dime qué cualidades
tiene tu pareja ideal alguien que lea
que sea divertido muy aventurero quieres
que sea extrovertido y social es
importante para mí que sea ambicioso si
tienen metas o algo que pasión eso es lo
que podría traer mieres a alguien
cercano a su familia sin duda quiero
alguien que sea muy bueno con sus padres
me llevo muy bien con las mamás ellas me
adoran yo lo digo fue un placer conocer
un rostro no soy una diosa yo soy muy
linda adiós
sería algo por aquí bien
amigos relájate su intento no encuentro
la manera de integrar me hablaste más
secreta
[Música]
bueno de acuerdo
pelirroja yo
una más allá sí y
fue un placer conocerlas adiós
3 de alguna de ellas podría salir
convenios sí sí por él es muy callado
les juro que están debajo de todo eso
hay una personalidad
recuérdame tu nombre allison muy bien
cuál es la primera impresión que tienes
de tenis con lo poco que viste de él
siento que abre más contigo que con él
pero si es un entorno desconocido así
que no lo culpo
aceptaría su solicitud en una red social
no es el tipo de hombre que me gusta si
lo viera entender creo que lo rechazaría
en los referías está bien eres ría
sedena y suele tener una relación muy
cercana con sus amigas crees que podría
acelerar lo o depende hay una parte de
mí que sigue trabajando en sus
inseguridades así que quizás no me
agrade pero creo que con el tiempo estoy
muy segura que podría manejarlo mejor
buscas una pareja que reafirme
constantemente tu relación creo que eso
depende de mí pero me han además recibir
algún comentario de vez en cuando pero
sin duda eso es algo interno y personal
siento que es algo que debo hacer por mí
misma entonces apuestas más por el amor
propio que por esta vía es muy bien
siento que estamos en una cita
estoy tan nerviosa
ya viste a denis y cuando hablé con él
me pareció que se veía bien me entiende
no claro se ve bien
solo eso me hubiera gustado hablar más
con él pero seré sincera contigo él
acaba de cambiar de carrera y todo eso
está en una etapa de autodescubrimiento
es algo en lo que no quieres verte
involucrada bajo ninguna
circunstancia soy o también cambia de
carrera se siente en mí pensaba y en la
vida me estaba dejando atrás pero no es
así si eres perezoso y no tienes ninguna
ambición en la vida eso sí es una muy
mala señal bien pero cambiar de carrera
y seguir descubriendo intereses no yo
soy joven él es joven y creo que todos
los días hay algo que podemos mejorar
para poder madurar él sigue su propio
camino no sé quién para decirle santo
cielo griego resolverte si bien tu
tiempo se acabó también a díaz si eres
estiajes herencias con placer
sí creo que ya tengo la que puede ser sí
sí estoy segura
[Música]
hola qué tal estás en tus pantalones
me gusta
muéstrame lo eso me interesa mucho ahora
estoy tratando de vestirme más a la moda
suelo usar camisetas vintage es lo que
más uso oye no te lo había preguntado
pero porque terminaron cabrito
terminamos dos veces la primera pasa
bueno fue mi primera relación larga así
que quedé ciego de alguna manera siento
que ella me enseñó muchas cosas pero
creo que terminamos porque yo sentía que
siempre estábamos juntos y no teníamos
equilibrio así que bueno solo he tenido
una relación larga y duró poco más de un
año tuve exactamente el mismo problema
solíamos estar juntos y nos hicimos más
o menos dependientes el uno del otro y
no pude tolerarlo fue espantoso y dime a
quién habría elegido
de verdad también sabes que creo que es
porque
ya señaló tu mano pensé que era genial
pensé algo como a mí me parece increíble
estoy impresionada bien
perfecto
ya veo como te centres genial público
mis mejores vistas ya veremos quién lo
hace mejor
tienen que enviarme una foto entendido y
por supuesto jubilee vive intensamente